-Thank you so much
for being here, buddy.
It's the first time
I'm introducing you as a dad.
-As a father, yeah.
-You're a father.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the best news!
-Thank you. Yeah, it's huge.
It's pretty excellent.
-Is your phone just all pictures
of kids now?
-Oh, for good reason I don't
have it on me right now.
-Or else you'd show it?
-Or else I would absolutely
show it to you
'cause I am 100% that dad.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I think there are
whole server farms
dedicated to just pictures
of my baby now.
Like tens of --
it's amazing how many pictures
you can take of one baby.
-Yeah, what -- Was it always
like sunsets and brunches?
-Or, yeah --
-Breakfast?
-She gets pasta sauce on her
face, we need 10,000 of those.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah.
-Are you showing it to strangers
and everybody like you --
-Checked into the hotel
last night.
First thing I did was like,
"Hey, did you know I had a baby?
[ Laughter ]
Have you seen my baby?
She's super cute."
And I know all parents think
their kids are super cute,
but my kid is, like,
really super cute.
-Your wife is
Jodie Turner-Smith,
a very talented actor.
So please, give her my best.
I saw this online
that made me laugh.
This is your wife rocking
a Pacey T-shirt.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
No, this popped up like
eight or nine months
into our relationship.
I'm not exactly sure
who the Amazon seller is
that keeps the Pacey shirts
on hand,
but she is their core customer.
-Did you guys always know that
you were destined --
that you were going to
get married?
-I knew the moment she asked me.
[ Laughter ]
-She asked you?
-She asked me, yeah,
on New Year's Eve.
We were in Nicaragua.
It was very beautiful,
incredibly romantic.
We're walking down the beach,
and she asked me to marry her.
-She just said will you -- Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, there was,
like, a preamble.
There was a lead-up to it.
-Yeah.
Did you know that
it was going to happen?
-I did not know,
but she was quite adamant,
and she was right.
This is the best choice
I ever made.
-Aw, that's what I'm
talking about, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's awesome.
Congrats on the great reviews.
-Thank you.
-"Dr. Death" --
It's streaming now on Peacock.
Everyone, get Peacock.
By the way, super easy
to get Peacock.
-And a little bonus news --
You don't actually have to pay.
You should, of course.
But you can watch the show
just by downloading the app.
-Yeah, so it's free.
-It's free.
-Yeah, so just do it.
-Love that.
-Free is good.
-Free is great.
-I tied it, 'cause I'm like,
"I should. It's NBC Peacock."
-I mean, you kind of got to.
-Yeah.
So I jumped in to it.
I know, but I jumped in
to see how hard it was.
It's easy.
-Yeah.
-It's fantastic.
-Super simple.
-Yeah.
-No excuses.
-No.
But this is based on
a troubling true story.
-Yes.
-Craziness.
Is this -- How did you find out
about the story?
-I missed -- So, this is
based on a true story.
This terrible doctor,
Christopher Duntsch,
had 38 surgeries,
33 of which were catastrophic,
2 of which ended in death.
A third one of his patients
has since died.
Just could not be any worse.
-Yeah.
-I missed all of this
while it was happening.
So when the job came to me,
Patrick Macmanus,
who is the executive producer
and the writer, he --
we're talking on the phone and
he's giving me the whole pitch.
And he basically said, "Look,
there's an amazing podcast.
Go listen to the podcast and
then let's talk about it again."
So I went and listened to
the podcast.
And it -- I mean, it's like
a horror story.
You know, you cannot believe --
-It's even worse
than a horror story.
-Yeah, it is 'cause it's true,
and real bodies were damaged.
And this man is probably going
to spend the rest of his life
in jail, as he well should.
But the system that created him
still exists.
And that's, to me, what's so
scary about this story,
is that he's the kind of
perfect storm of evil man
with bad intentions, but it took
a whole system around him
to allow him to keep on doing
that damage to people
and that system still exists.
-Gosh. You're phenomenal.
Also it's Alec Baldwin
and Christian Slater too.
-AnnaSophia Robb -- We got
a bunch of good folks in there.
-Watch the show.
You're going to love it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Joshua Jackson
in "Dr. Death."
Take a look at this.
-What happened with Mr. Peduo?
-Well, the surgery was normal,
nothing out of the ordinary.
With the exception
of a scrub tech
who had the pace of molasses
and a resident --
-It says here the procedure
was delayed.
For a week.
-Yes.
There were some challenges
with the scheduling,
but we accommodated.
-Challenges?
-The access surgeons,
they were all booked up.
-I was a nurse for many years
before entering management.
I'm so fluent
in doctor bull[bleep]
I can whiff it all the way
from Fort Worth.
-Hey, look, I'm not trying to
cause trouble here,
but I think there are some
fragile male egos in this town
that don't like my style.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Joshua Jackson, everybody!
"Dr. Death" is streaming
now on Peacock!